all right guys bang-bang special episode
of lunch Monday today while Wall Street
tried to get rich the rest of us just
trying to get our lunch money right as
you can see I've got the beautiful
intelligent plenum Air Nova as always
she has a sailor outfit on but I also
have Zack Prince founder co-founder and
CEO of block 5 here well he just looks
like I put on a button-up shirt first
time we hang out with y'all on this you
put more effort into getting dressed up
the planner did today
I showed you the pants you might not say
that I'm very dressed I love it
take take 30 seconds and I introduce
yourself and tell us what's up a block
fine yeah so I'm a a you know tech
startup guy my entire career I grew up
in Texas so you hear me say y'all when
I'm talking about stuff on the show I've
been a passionate cryptocurrency
investor since 2014 and in 2017 I
decided to start a company around
building financial services for this
asset class so so block 5 I mean if you
watched lunch money we're a sponsor but
we're the leading provider of products
that enable folks to earn interest on
their cryptocurrency buy and sell
cryptocurrency with no fees and also get
loans secured by their cryptocurrency so
that you can get cash without selling
your Bitcoin or other crypto assets so
the company is doing great
we're having a lot of fun building stuff
for this asset class that didn't exist
before and thanks for having me on I'm
excited to chat about whatever topics we
have on the agenda for today for sure
every time I call Zak Zak is more
excited usually founders get tired and
they and it's kind of like the
excitement wears off but every time I
talk to him he's more excited and the
company's getting bigger and bigger so
I'm excited to have him here I I think I
first met Zak it like a holiday party
you guys had no you can't I remember you
can brought you to a happy hour at our
office our small office that we grew out
of like a couple weeks after that
and I just couldn't help but think what
the hell you were doing with a guy like
him I'm still wondering that dude
I'm still wondering that joke all right
what's the first topic what do we got so
the u.s. is hitting its or hit its high
a single day of new coronavirus cases
with more than 45,000 and 500 breaking
April's records so cases are spiking but
people are saying can we really be in a
second wave when we haven't finished the
first wave yeah but I think that we
started to go down and that's what
people said in the first wave right I
guess but I feel like we're still in the
first wave well alright so I want to
hear Zacks opinion on this because Zack
is from Texas and I feel like Arizona
Florida Texas like many of the states
that are warmer and opened up first it
seems like that's where it's spiking but
I also surprising what is that what are
you hearing from people that you like
grew up with their states to live in
Texas well I'll tell you what people
said when this first started to happen
down there okay nobody's gonna tell me
to wear a mask nobody's gonna tell me
that I can't shut you know that I can't
run my business this is America this is
freedom I own guns and you know you
can't tell me what to do
that's the attitude you know and so it's
gonna be really interesting to see how
this plays out because you're gonna
start to see factions within the US
where you know also New York New Jersey
and Connecticut announced yesterday that
like Texas people have to quarantine if
they come to New York and they're not
gonna follow those rules Texas people
are gonna come to New York they're gonna
do whatever they want just like they do
in Texas
and so it's gonna get weird and look
it's scary you know like my my parents
are coming to visit us at our house in
upstate New York and they're older and
they're not like their immune systems
aren't compromised but it's like it's
it's hard to see us getting back to a
world where we can just hang out with
grandparents and live life normally
without being a little bit worried about
coronavirus until they have a vaccine so
that's how I think about it Michael
science just needs to solve this and as
fast as possible are they gonna drive or
fly they're driving they're driving yeah
so like I went and I saw my parents for
for Mother's Day I don't think I've told
everyone that yet and plena did not come
I went by myself my brothers went and we
were actually like we're not normally
kind of germaphobes in any sense like
literally we'll share food we'll do
whenever we were like a little nervous
so we drove and like it was a little
weird
Riley you like obsessively washing your
hands like I don't know it was just it
was weird and my dad is like you know
he's probably very similar I'm assuming
to your father which is like you know he
told me at one point I take a
multivitamin like I'll be fine and I was
like that's not how this works there's
no good answer it's a little
embarrassing I mean like on the global
scale you know you see some countries
that are actually like just taking
science seriously and following the
rules and then in America a lot of a lot
of places were just like yeah absolutely
[Laughter]
[Music]
this year and and it's so sad because my
grandfather has never been to the US so
he calls me literally every weekend he's
like how are things looking over there
like I'm looking on the news it's not
looking great but like is New York okay
and I was like New York made a comeback
New York went from the worst it's and
now they're corn sitting people coming
in New York all right what's next so
millions of Americans will fall off an
income cliff when extra $600 in
unemployment benefits ends next month
first of all what's an income cliff well
the the big things here are savings
rates up 33 percent and personal income
rate is up 10.5% over the last couple of
months which seems like good things
those people are saving more money right
they're not going out they're not
spending it whatever then personal
income is actually up so you think of an
economic crisis and everyone's like oh
my god no one's gonna have any money but
because of the stimulus check that you
know 800 1200 bucks whatever people got
and then also the unemployment an extra
600 so it's not just $600
whatever your state gave you plus 600 so
why people were making more money on
unemployment than they were at their
jobs as I keep saying like that's
probably more an indictment on like we
don't pay people enough when they're not
on unemployment but that ends July 31st
yeah and so now all the sudden you're
gonna just be on either regular
unemployment where you're gonna have no
income
that's what the paid source does do you
get unemployment for as long as you're
unemployed I think there's just like a
finite amount I maybe six months a year
whatever like you can basically pull it
for a certain period of time and then
you can't get any more we think Zack I
think it's gonna be really interesting
to see how this plays out politically so
it's an election year and like like the
reason that you know folks haven't felt
the economic pain of the loss of jobs
and this whole situation is because of
the stimulus a lot of people are doing
better than they were before because of
the stimulus a lot of people are
probably going to be conflicted you know
in the first half of July around okay do
I go take my job back at the restaurant
where I'm not getting paid enough I
completely agree with you on that on
that point calm and then give up my
unemployment benefits for making more
money but then you know it does does the
existing you know government in the u.s.
want to let people fall off the cliff so
it's gonna be interesting to see how it
plays out I think this is gonna be a
moment where America kind of wakes up a
little bit and and realizes that you
know we can we can provide a better you
know kind of floor on incomes and social
safety net stuff and it's not gonna hurt
our economy dollars you know the thing
that I saw that cracked me up is
obviously there's a financial incentive
to stay on unemployment especially if
there's this weekly like extra six
hundred bucks but even if that goes away
the unemployment can still be a
financial incentive and so what they
were talking about is should they extend
it you know maybe the end of the year or
should they not with the with the
additional benefit but then there was
talk of like a go back to work bonus so
they're saying like hey basically could
we pay somebody like a one-time amount
to get them off the extra on
unemployment and get them to go back to
work and so I was reading about it and
they were like yeah that the bonus would
be $450
like hold on a second I'm not a
mathematician but you're telling me that
I could get unemployment plus $600 a
week every single week for like a year
or I can just get a one-time $450 I'm
probably just gonna stay up and I'm
gonna make more money doing that than
the one-time bonus so I do think that
it's like they probably have the right
idea as to how to manipulate and
incentivize people it's just you got to
make the numbers work where you could
actually make the math work and you got
to get it approved politically yeah that
but here's the other part to that I
think is is hard that complicates all
this for the analysis is like you have
people right now that have kind of that
social safety net right and and they've
been able to mitigate a lot of the
damage but we were talking yesterday
like my estimation is 20 percent of
small businesses aren't coming back
right like by the time we get through
the whole thing so if that happens
that'd be 10 percent of jobs in America
just aren't there so even if they get
off of the unemployment because that's
will benefit ends what do they do like
like literally there's no job to go back
to right so you get in a situation where
like you're just gonna have high
unemployment for a while yeah but that
means that the floor if that happened
that means to absolute floor so we were
at 3.5% unemployment in February before
the pandemic now it's a historic low
plus the now you've added 10% jobs
disappeared so you're basically at like
a floor of call it you know twelve to
fourteen percent unemployment you look
you won't be able to go below that
because the jobs literally don't exist
for a while right and I mean that's
incredible unemployment yeah I mean not
not to mention the trends that have been
going on for a long time you know COBIT
aside of technology you know removing a
lot of jobs that's gonna happen to to
planes and trucks and cars soon you know
I think there's like another five to ten
percent that you know their job is
something related to driving a thing and
like that's gonna go away it's just a
question of whether it's five years from
now or 25 years from now this concept is
gonna keep coming up and there's got to
be in my opinion there's got to be some
type of political solution you know you
can't just have everyone finding for
themselves all the time when there's
literally not enough jobs to go around
yeah for sure
alright what's next Disney is postponing
the reopening of Disneyland it
originally was supposed to open on July
17th but now they're like I don't know I
kind of just feel like this is one of
those things that people are like duh
but also if you think like where people
really gonna go to Disneyland with like
masks and gloves and like hand sanitizer
hanging out of their pocket I think the
family's from Texas Georgia yeah
wait dig Zach they definitely were I
mean look everything that opens up
people are gonna come whether it's
sporting events or casinos or other
stuff people are going to go and you
know the companies have to try and be a
little bit responsible about it so I
guess that's why I'd is knees making the
call I don't know if a regulator told
them to do it or not but yeah people go
they'll have no problem filling up look
at the cruise ships they like sold out
they're like we're reopening in August
it's like we ever booked so my my
favorite thing that I've seen on the
reopening is the casinos I've seen to
two different things so one is a video
of what literally was packed what you
know bigger than they've ever been like
a home was absurd - was I saw a video
where they people are sitting at the
table and there's basically like
Plexiglas in front of the table and they
can put their hands under in like a slot
to play like poker or whatever at the
table but there was nothing in between
the people and some people had masks
some people didn't but just like
protecting the dealer and then I saw one
that literally was like a personal cute
like you walked in you sat in your seat
and you were surrounded on three sides
by Plexiglas and you could put your
hands under and play games and then you
also weren't interacting with the person
next to you and I was just thinking to
myself like if they're doing that at the
casino like what if every single place
you went that's what society turned into
like the coffee shop person doing what
doing Plexiglas if they can't the tables
can't be six feet apart but honestly a
casino is the last place I want to be
right now
well no I'm really good at blackjack you
want you played one time and you made it
you made a lot of money yes
but you only made a lot of money for two
reasons one beginner's luck which is
which is the thing that's the thing
that's good but to also I was taking
chips off the table the entire time so
you could never actually lose money so
every time that she would go up I would
take like half the stack and she keep
playing it always looked like she had
the same stack there's a psycho players
the other players at your table yeah
they'd be impressed but he kept taking
them off because there's a psychological
thing if you know that you got this huge
stack you'll just keep betting more and
more all right so our would you go to
Disneyland right now absolutely Zach
would you go no I wouldn't I mean word
we're a bit more conservative in terms
of this stuff but people will like it's
the reason why I wouldn't go is because
I don't I hate wearing the mask like
I'll wear to go in the stores or you
know whatever I have to do but like if
you said to me you have to wear this
mask all day long and walk around
outside that just sounds horrible well
imagine dragging two little kids with
you and trying to put a mask on them
this is the weirdest thing ever do like
mom why do I have to wear this mask all
the time no they hate it man it's
torture you know like like
five-year-olds don't learn well over the
Internet it's just not a thing that like
works I didn't realize how much I like
read people like when they talk like I
read their lips or whatever cuz when you
have a mask on I don't know what you're
saying I'm like why are you claiming to
be a lip-reader
yes apparently my hearing is not that
good facial expressions are a huge part
of body language and so you're talking
to people and you're like I don't know
if you're mad or grumpy or happy or
excited to see me or like you have no
idea what's going on so hard all right
what's going on Bill Ackman Bill
Ackman's new blank check company maybe a
four billion dollar bet on a so-called
mature unicorn are you guys is walk for
mature unicorn we're an emerging mature
unicorn that's great answer you hear
that everyone
laughs I calm no horrid well says a lot
of people forget Bill Ackman was it
three years ago people were laughing at
him he had a cut staff he was like
taking the subway taking the whole thing
right and he said I'm gonna go back to
focusing on the fundamentals and I'm
gonna go back to investing I'm not gonna
do any press not gonna do anything and
he came back and last year a lot of
people forget he was the best performing
hedge fund last year all of Wall Street
he returned over 50% I think and and he
killed it with a with a hedge against
macroeconomic uncertainty going into
Cove it yeah that he had a bet using
options that that made him like a
billion dollar profit and pretty much
ensured that his phone's gonna have
great performance for the entirety of
this year too and this dollar bet I
think it wasn't he made two billion
dollars yeah this this thing that he's
doing it's creating a specialty purpose
acquisition company shamov poly a Bhatia
and a number of other folks are in on
this trend as well and I'm a huge fan of
this trend conceptually there's like two
things at play here one is why our
company staying private so damn long and
getting all the growth squeezed out of
them while they're in private markets
and then you just dump it into the
public market at the end of its growth
trajectory and the other is just new and
interesting ways to go public from a
company's perspective instead of the old
IPO process which has some challenges in
terms of incentive alignment certainty
pricing so I'm a huge fan of this it's I
think it's great I think you're gonna
see more of it do you think that so I
agree with you completely do you think
that this is only possible for people
with big names so Chum off Bill Ackman
like people who have large followings
since you're basically asking investors
to go blind pool right and for those
they don't know blind pool basically
means I'm committing capital but I
actually don't know which company right
so in a fund structure you give a
manager capital and they say I'm gonna
go invest in companies that fit this
profile so their early stage late stage
whatever but you don't actually know the
companies saying here they're basically
say
give us the money now and then we'll go
find the company to acquire and brings
kind of like when I was fifteen and I
would be like hey Dad can I go to the
mall and get like you know fifty bucks
and he'll be like for a while and I'll
find that like that except except if
your dad had the option to tell you that
you're not allowed to buy a certain
thing once you made the visible so there
is this little like there is this little
check on on incentives towards the end
where once a company has been identified
investors have the option to not
participate and just get their money
back instead we call that the super
short shorts option no you cannot have
that it's too far away from your knee or
whatever knowing your dad he would have
loved the veto power
so I guess do we think that it's only
people with big names are gonna be able
to do this or do we think it'll become
pervasive where we're pretty much every
asset manager does it I think it's gonna
become more pervasive I think you do
need to have an established track record
or brand or you know you need to be some
kind of a known quantity to folks
looking to invest because they're taking
a flier on on the decision that you're
gonna make in the future about what
company you're gonna use to buy this
back but it's been really successful
recently you know Virgin Galactic
draftkings a couple of other companies
have gone public this way and they do it
at lower market caps relative to what we
typically think of in unicorn land and
they're all you know a lot of them are
up you know 2 3 4 5 X since they hit the
public markets and so they've performed
incredibly well but the performance does
that have to do with the merger
companies so basically the whole idea is
Bill Ackman's gonna have an entity cut
whatever it's called he basically would
go to a founder and say hey I like your
company do you want to go public the
founder would say yes I want to operate
my company in the public markets bill
says I've got 4 billion dollars that are
sitting here that I will use to buy
first a percentage they don't buy the
whole thing and buy percentage now the
company is
publicly listed and then it operates
just like any other stock so the benefit
of this is that you don't have to go
through the whole cumbersome IPO process
right and there's a big difference in
terms of how and when it gets priced so
let's say pomp is a spat guy and pulling
a year a traditional investment banker
who wants us to go public the normal way
if I do a deal with pomp using his back
we agree to the price and I know with
certainty the price we're going to go
public yet the deal is done if I work
with you as an investment banker to do
an IPO you say oh well Zach I think the
company is gonna come in around this
range but I need you to sign all these
papers and agree to pay me a bunch of
fees and then we're gonna go on a road
show and collect feedback and then we'll
kind of find out the price and it's like
it's a lot it's a lot different in terms
of that level of certainty when you're
going into the deal all right
Boston what's up okay so Boston just
banned its government from using facial
recognition technology and slightly
unrelated this morning I was reading the
news and it said that a Michigan man was
arrested after he was misidentified by
facial recognition yeah that's the whole
thing so I actually think that this is
awesome finally Boston got something
right so I could say that with someone
from Bulgaria in North Carolina in Texas
on you but no basically the whole idea
is just like the facial recognition
algorithms there's a last things that
show that they won are racially
discriminatory or just inaccurate and so
I think it's where these things where
people are like hey look if you are
optimizing for the effectiveness of the
police facial recognition technology
sounds great but if it's gonna literally
like in Michigan tell you the wrong
person to go arrest like it just causes
more problems than it actually provides
solutions like why are we gonna use it
but is that the minority of cases is
that the majority of cases where they
get it wrong in my view is so if if you
talk to people that are in Arizona Texas
Florida like people who are very kind of
personal freedom individual liberties if
you are going to misidentify one person
if you're violating one person's rights
like it's not worth doing it for
everybody
I tend to agree especially something
like this like we all look now and I
don't know exact us but played and I
have seen a bunch of movies and
documentaries all stuff about like
people who got put in prison for you
know 5 10 30 years whatever it is back
in the 70s and 80s technology right it's
your DNA technology or whatever it was
imagine in today's day and age being
wrongfully accused and when you go to
court in front of the judge they're like
yep the algorithm says blow whatever
like what yeah we think I think I think
it's there I move on Boston's part I
think you have to be super careful with
this stuff it's not just facial
recognition but they've found you know
other types of identification technology
and different algorithms to be you know
have like basically unintentional racism
built into them and so there's there's
two big things there that you have to be
really careful of privacy racism and
then also you know are the false
positives worth the you know upside of
maybe solving a couple extra crimes and
you know I'm on the side of like you
just got to go really slow with this
stuff and it is scary to me I'm
generally not like a huge privacy person
like I know my data is everywhere I'm
fine with it being like you know sold or
whatever but it does feel weird to think
of living in a world where like
everything you do you know that there's
like a video camera watching like that's
just a little too far and the Big
Brother camp for me the thing that I
think we talked about this one time
before on a show is then there's a bunch
of legislation that's around this idea
of like let's say he's a blocks down the
street and you're picked up by a
government camera whether it's law
enforcement or something else should
there be a rule where like they have 30
days to tell you that they've actually
acquired quote-unquote your data they've
acquired your face in a database so kind
of the awareness component but then also
there's talk of should they also have
some sort of life to the data so if if
your face for example doesn't help them
solve a crime
in six months or 12 months or whatever
it is they have to get rid of it right
and they can't your face forever and
then like one day in the future be like
oh we know every single playsets except
for God for you know 30 years and it
feels like those types of limitations
are probably good but again it's like
who's gonna get that a you know through
the political process I have no clue
yeah I think we can all agree that we
don't want to we don't want to become
China where your credit score for
example isn't just based on you know
your financial life it's also based on
like you know whether you showed up to
work on time and all this like social
stuff it's like it's it's there's a
there's a very delicate balance right I
will say do you know I camera if I told
you the story but I'm like I think as a
society we become hyper aware that we're
being taped one day this like two years
ago when I used to go to the fortune
office is super early to write term
sheet so I would leave my apartment at
5:00 a.m. and that day they I saw that
they hadn't picked up my trash so there
was like a trash thing nearby this
grocery store so I went but I
okay so I threw away the trash and then
I started running to get to make the
subway together to get on the subway you
know it's like okay whatever camera just
saw me so me like throw away a bag of
stuff and start running like what does
if anything happen in that area I'm
going to jail alright no makes me feel
better that other weird [ __ ] the other
thing that I do think is really
interesting around this is it's not just
facial recognition either like license
plate readers right this whole idea they
could put a camera and every single car
that goes by in New York I think
everyone pretty much knows that like
they'll use the EZ Pass like the toll
booths right for somebody they'll use
license plate readers like all of that
stuff again conceptually mmm people are
like oh of course the police do that but
then you like started thinking about the
should they do that you know what is the
violation of
in this one cell phone location data
like study did this one freaked me out
there was a study that showed they took
an anonymized cell phone data and they
basically started to label every single
person who it was and what they
basically did was super easy it is
waited till you brought your phone back
home and they just look to see who owned
the house they were like it reverse
engineer we know who everybody is right
crazy
yeah all right what show us let's go to
the last topic this ridiculous Harry and
was it Megan Megan Megan you know
they're now they're not real royalty
they have signed they have signed with a
speaking agency that represents the
Obamas in the Clintons and they will
speak about racial justice gender equity
and environmental concerns and Harry
will speak about mental health so um
this is really interesting because when
they were with the Queen and when they
were like Royals officially they
couldn't just pick what they talked
about they had to talk about whatever
the castle decided they talked about so
a lot of times it would be things of
interest to the Queen but this is
different so what is your question do
you have questions for us my question is
yeah how do you do you like here in my
oh I mean first up here he's also like a
fellow ginger so there's a there's an
element for me of like you know women
think he's good-looking he has red hair
like that's like good for the cause good
for the cause so so yeah I mean look
those are all great topics and and I've
watched I can't remember what show was
the camera it was a documentary or not
but like you know I imagine being born
into this family where on the one hand
you never have to work a day in your
life you've got all the money in the
world anything you want to do but on the
other you don't have the freedom to you
mess up in public or like mr. shott or
miss speak or whatever and I think they
kind of said you know screw it we're
gonna we're gonna tap out and and we're
gonna become you know pseudo tabloids
celebrities to make money when we need
to and and apparently one of the things
our gonna do is these speaking
engagements the list of topics is spot
on
like great the more people who can go to
talk about this stuff and influence the
world to move in the right direction on
it the better so you know they're on the
team they're on the team in my view in a
lot of ways maybe especially because a
lot of times what what the Royals talk
about is completely out of touch with
what's happening in society at the
moment so I think this is spot-on
some people have speculated that they're
gonna start a venture firm um I'm
curious if you think they have political
ambitions maybe but I have a much easier
question than all of this what if they
left the royal family how come everyone
keeps calling them Prince Harry he's not
a prince anymore that's his title but
like you don't get that so it's like
saying that you're the CEO of a company
and they leave the company no one keeps
calling you the CEO the whole thing is
so nebulous man like the fact that
there's still a king and queen of
England is kind of like goofy and like
it doesn't it exists but it doesn't
actually exist like it's all this weird
nebulous like did you did you hear how
they make money we went down a big
rabbit hole the Queen gets paid $1 a
pound or one pound per head per head not
only in England but also all their
territories like Australia all the stuff
every year one pound per person goes to
the Queen and that's their revenue
source in a home I mean they own like a
ridiculous amount of land and castles
and horse but like that's all stuff that
you would expect right but when I heard
that literally the tax is one pound per
person annually I started you know
googling really how many people live in
Australia how many people live in
England and then the Queen I guess gets
to decide like Oh Zach you've been a
good boy this year you will get a
hundred pounds you know like this big
weird
like he gets knighted you know like
who's gonna Knight and they do the
little sword thing it's like it's
ridiculous here's what I will say though
is I think that 2020 and the internet
like just this period of time it was
inevitable that like this structure
would break down because it's very much
built on like controlling information
and like all that kind of stuff and so
to see them leave and that structure not
full he's actually pretty interesting
like I would have thought that the
second that you kind of have like
rebellion from inside you would have
seen like people being all right like
this is stupid
but I think he's they love it People
magazine has an entire reporter
dedicated just to covering the Royals
really yeah but like does the Queen like
and I mean this is the nicest most
venerable way possible but isn't she a
super old and not doing anything yeah do
we think the conspiracy that the Royals
killed I think I read on the internet
that's a possibility I I think that what
he obviously like shook things up but I
don't think it'll start to dismantle
until maybe the Queen's gone and then
who gets the like the top job after she
goes I don't even know who that guy is
he's good he's easy irrelevant it sounds
like no no all right Zak do you think in
10 years the King Queen structure still
exists yes absolutely
why not watch that go like marry a
princess that's just that's just in the
UK right there's a ton of other kings
and queens all around in random places I
mean Thailand's got a whole thing
Singapore has got like a thing like I
feel like those are more like the actual
governing of the country is done by
those people in England it delivers
there's all different flavor
really yeah like I think I think in
Thailand it's a little bit like the king
is off to the side there's also a
government it used to be elected
government now it's a military
government and there's weird back and
forth but you know and sometimes like
it's like the king who's just kind of a
total [ __ ] dictator type of vibe like
it you know alright so last thing so
princess eugenie mmm she she moved to
New York and she worked here and she was
supposed to get married this year but it
was postponed due to the your name is
Eugenia before before we and wrap this
up with Zack we have two friends I'm not
gonna say their name so not sure if
they're comfortable with it or not but
they're very dear friends of Polina and
I and last night they texted us with a
very concerning issue which was they had
spent probably sounds like 30 minutes 60
minutes whatever was debating and
researching what continent New Zealand
design is if you think of the seven
continents
there's Asia Australia right or North
America like there's all the ones that
you would be kind of in and around but
it's New Zealand part of it so I you
know like ah I've got this supercomputer
yes I'll show his own concept so what is
so I started to Google around and the
Wikipedia description I'm gonna read to
everyone because it is so ridiculous and
confusing that this is literally what he
said you're just making [ __ ] up New
Zealand is not part of the continent of
Australia but of the separate submerged
continent of Zealandia New Zealand and
Australia are both part of the ocean sub
region known as Australasia with New
Guinea being in Milan asian asian so I
think that Wikipedia either made up
three continents I've never heard before
we're not just super confused what is
like what is going on with New Zealand
yeah I mean it's all it's all just a
bunch of stuff that you know people who
thought they were really smart and we're
viewed as being really smart at the time
took a flyer on right like why countries
exist what continent
her name's like it's all kind of like oh
yeah and then at one point some dude
most of the time because it was history
was like I hereby say Australia is the
continent and the people like what about
the islands he's like I don't know don't
figure that [ __ ] out later that is oshi
al anbiya so this is now I want to use
this as like a trivia question is to ask
people like what continent is New
Zealand but the problems I don't know
the answer like you can't ask a question
you don't actually know the answer to
right the answer is none or all of them
or yeah or just make up something that
makes people confused and makes you
sound smart and you you exactly all
right before we wrap up normally we
explain block Phi so take take a minute
or two and kind of let's just walk
through the product so people understand
let's start with the u.s. dollar loan
product how does that work US dollar
loan product if you're someone who owns
cryptocurrency and you don't want to
sell it but you want some cash to make a
down payment on a house or pay down
other debt or buy an engagement ring you
can use our loan product to do that in a
tax efficient manner so if you bought
Bitcoin at a thousand and it's ninety
five hundred today if you sell your
Bitcoin you have to pay taxes on an
eighty five hundred dollar gain if you
get a loan against your Bitcoin not only
do you not have to pay taxes on the gain
if you use the proceeds of the loan for
investment purposes so let's say you buy
you know Amazon stock with it you get to
deduct the interest from your taxes so
this crypto this loan structure is
something that has been in the wealth
management toolkit for a long time as
folks begin to accumulate wealth and our
loan product just brings it to you know
crypto
so you can do it with Bitcoin no no
brainer the crypto exchange yeah so
crypto exchange we um you can buy and
sell crypto on block five the trading is
integrated directly into our interest
account products so you can send money
into your account via wire or stable
coins you can earn eight point six
interest on it while it's sitting in
cash and then you can buy Bitcoin
whenever you know pomper Jason or
somebody else gives you the the Bitcoin
buy signal and then you buy Bitcoin on
block five with no fees whatsoever
and then you're immediately earning
interest on Bitcoin in your interest
account it's super simple it's actually
in our mobile app now up until this week
it was only available on the web the
trading function was only available on
the web so you can now trade in the
mobile app and on the web you're earning
interest and we were the you know first
place to integrate all of these things
and do the interest in one spot so if
you've got your cryptocurrency like
sitting on coinbase or something or
you're thinking about buying Bitcoin
you're not sure when you want to and you
like the idea of earning 8.6 percent on
your cash just getting paid to wait when
you know savings rates at banks or sub
1% everywhere you should check so and
what is the rate eight point six percent
API on the stable coins and is it still
six percent for for Bitcoin right now
yeah six percent on Bitcoin four point
five percent on aetherium I think like
coin is around like three percent or
something like that so got it and then
last but not least I think the thing
that a lot of people are waiting for is
the Bitcoin rewards credit card I don't
know what you can say about that but
maybe kind of just give us a quick
overview what that's gonna look like
because I need another credit card yeah
so this is it's gonna be gonna be a ton
of fun like you know every product that
we've created a block fight has been
something that that I've wanted
personally and I think the big coin
rewards credit card is the most exciting
thing that that we're gonna launch we
the idea is simple so right now if you
have a good credit score you're probably
spending your money on some type of
rewards card you're either getting cash
back or airline points or you know Chase
Sapphire points our credit card is gonna
work exactly the same way except instead
of airline points you're gonna get
Bitcoin cash back every time you spend
money on the card and that Bitcoin will
then go instantly into our interest
account if you wanted to or you can you
know trade it for cash or withdraw to a
different wallet
and we were originally planning on
launching it in q4 that's still our goal
we might still be in the beta in q4 of
this year but the co vid stuff slowed
down some of the partners we work with
to launch this product it's it's an old
things yeah you need like a card network
you need a bank you need a payment
processing partner but the teams working
really hard on it and I'm so excited to
launch it we're gonna do a ton of fun
marketing too you know talking about how
airline miles suck and by the way they
kind of sucked before COBIT now they
really suck because you're not even
flying anywhere so like if they were
annoying to use before now now they're
really no ideas so we hope it'll be a
good moment for Bitcoin right everyone
who's excited about Bitcoin will
hopefully get the card and then you're
paying with something that's got a big
coin logo and it looks like a sweet
piece of plastic and people are asking
you about it and you can earn you know
earn your rewards in a in an asset that
could appreciate massively in value
which is a lot different from what folks
have been done doing historically with
credit card rewards you know how Babe
Ruth you just step up to the plate and
call a shot and hit a home run I feel
like that's what you could do the credit
card like if you guys get it launched I
just don't see how it's not a hit I mean
look we talk we talk about stuff you
know on Twitter or other places like
like we could say like you know hey we
just hired this great person to do this
or trading is now available in the
mobile app and our entire feed is just
like wind credit card you know like
don't care like with wind credit cards
so we're excited about it we're working
really hard on it and it's definitely
coming
why do Bitcoin people not believe in
using like words when credit card it's a
I get it but it's dumb can you start out
with when moon I know but it's done okay
well I didn't realize it that we
everyone had to have a bit of a command
of the American languages you have it's
dumb but if it's fun different strokes
for different folks you're excited
talking about you know I get mark on
Harry nagging and Harry right it's fun
but it's dumb
so same same difference you you guys
will see it's not gonna be done when
they run for president the aristocracy
where you're taking
sors and like tapping people's shoulders
and doing all this like ludicrous stuff
and charging everybody in your thing one
pound a year like it's dumb it makes no
sense except for if you're the queen and
you're getting rich then it makes a lot
of sense sure exactly the best meme I
saw was that when Harry and Megan got
married and it was like oh this is the
UK's way of like regaining America
alright guys that's it for lunch Monday
today Zak is on Twitter what's your
Twitter account block 5 Zak Zak go check
them out
Blankfein calm slash lunch money is
where you can go sign up for all kinds
of cool stuff that we just talked about
and remember all she's trying to get
rich the rest of us just trying to get
our lunch money right
even through Blankfein get money get
paid see you guys later see ya
bang-bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on I'm an investor a
user and a huge fan what you're a bigger
fan of block fire than you are of me
block wise my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina
they've got three products they can give
you a US dollar loan you can earn up to
8.6 percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
8.6 percent interest on a deposit in an
interest-bearing account go do your own
research there's risks associated but
8.6% it's pretty compelling so click on
the link in the description say thanks
to the folks that block buy subscribe to
our channel like the video annoy plan in
the comment and we'll see you guys
tomorrow and be kind to your friends